yo something crazy oh it's awkward
between my girl now this weekend
why something went down like he's kind
of like what would you do does it have
to do with the lube
nah bruh so she was working on this like
shoot big shoot
and you know we haven't been spending a
lot of time together because she's
working because she's working okay i'm
in the bathroom watching movies
what wait watching boys are you talking
[ __ ] no
you're in the bathroom watching movies
oh okay you're jacking it
yeah right yeah in her crib
right i didn't know she was home and
then
you know you got the sound out loud and
i just hear her
like drop her back i'm like oh shoot
then
she was like i was like man are you home
she's like yeah i'm home and now i know
she heard me watching movies of course
so she goes uh i was like yo she was
like what are you doing in there i was
like you know she's slime
taking her you know taking a dump and
all that she was like okay cool and
she'd been quiet like the whole
oh no oh she knew anything why did you
just why did you just tell her you was
jacking off
well because women that's awkward yeah
exactly you don't like that no i don't
care
yeah what you don't care about you don't
care i think everybody
has to masturbate at one point or
another i think it's normal get your
pleasure i'd rather you tell me now i
feel like you're hiding something yeah
she heard that back and forth dialogue
with you and some other girl
over face time then yeah it's gonna get
weird if that's right what are you
watching you're watching like out of
some asian [ __ ] video
let us know what you like like the
journey girls and she's like
this is what you're into yeah exactly
wonder why
suggestions you might like when have i
said i like chicks with this
when have i ever gave you the idea that
first year big chance with big days
what about a bbw when have i ever
ever clicked on that oh
genre yeah i like bbws i like oh what
you do my thing is the dancing bear
bro oh you i'm about to put y'all a game
it's like bro so it's like all these
women
in this office right and they clapping
and it's like stripper come out with a
whole
bear that's what they uh and he'll just
put some uh cream on his penis and he'll
just come up to the girl [ __ ] they're
like oh
i guess it's my turn to suck dick yeah
i'm in the group activities you're in
the furry you're in the group back too
you're in a furry what's wrong what's
furry is like people in costumes having
sex
no no no cosplay yeah
uh furries are more like mascot costumes
like animals
yeah rather than like like a man in a
beer shoot getting sucked off yeah yeah
i'm not no i take the hell no you know
you [ __ ] up right yeah
what do you mean cause you said yeah you
said a guy in a beer suit
and a bunch of girls bear helmet yeah
yeah yeah that's that's
that's furries well because no because
he's on brand dancing bear
you see what i'm saying he's on yeah no
matter what you want to call it still a
man in the costume getting sucked off
and that's what you're into that's fine
he goes down he goes in a circle he goes
and they're all because they're all
women they're like yeah but he takes the
helmet off when he like he reveals
what's the rest of his body yeah which
means he's in the bear costume no no
he's just naked but naked he come out
with this cream and he only
that's insane you're into that yeah yeah
of all things yeah don't tell your girl
this
yeah because now i'm concerned
we need to reach out to you this is why
you shouldn't tell your girl now
why
it's not weird that he watches this bear
[ __ ] because he got something he got
that gag ball thing
so you should be watching like
dominatrix like yeah yeah but we lived
that though
you live yeah you want something she got
the battle she got a mask like that
[ __ ] she know how to match and she
was quite offended that y'all
brought that up i told her i was like
she wants the mask no she doesn't want
the man yeah she does
yes she does okay you're going to get
the gag ball you want the mask no you
put it but if you're on you got to
elevate yourself if you're watching
something different
would your girl be offended if it was
just like all black on black
because she's obviously not black she's
not a fan she doesn't care she won't
keep this big fat black chick
she you know yeah i think she's like
this what you're into like you feel like
fat because we we
teach it all the time she was like yo
what are you into that as well
nah yeah but nice again pouring in
relationships is always gonna be weird
and we do everything you know y'all do
everything yeah for real
we spice it up do you yeah with luke
i mean well yeah the loop take it to a
different level huh
oh you owe me money i mean you owe me
shoes bruh i know we talked about we
talked about that where was that man
yeah remember i lost the battery you're
trying to get off your little
masturbation
that's fine yeah i'd be careful on the
on the the bear costume's a little
strange yeah that is true
he takes he is that something you wish
you could have done it's like an obvious
it's an office setting
bro it's like different places so it's
like a bachelorette it's an office
it's a what else divorce parties
whatever it is
yeah i've seen it yeah i've never seen
it yeah i sat through and watched it you
ever watched that you ever watched the
english guy driving the taxi
all right come on where are you where
you heading
let's say i just pour you over right two
stops on the airport and just like
banks
i fast forward through all the talk bro
yeah [ __ ] that public uh
public agent uh bro it's like a guy acts
like he's
a public public agent agent yeah so he's
like oh you're a model you get like
these girls like beautiful off the
street he's like yo
can you model for me i give you like
like 10 000 c
uh euros okay cool like all right but
you have to go to the bushes
and she's like alright cool ten thousand
and they bad and then he's like yo for
thirty thousand
let me see your titty and she ain't got
that kind of money on the road like that
[ __ ] then he said like
[Applause]
and there's multiple videos of him
giving them cash like that
and i only agree that's all i'm over
here feeding into him
the camera just somehow is there i'm so
sorry i don't know what the [ __ ] i was
thinking
but i was like damn we can just dance 30
000 yeah
all right how's that only fans going cat
uh it's good
bro still climbing yeah it's good you
saw it
she told us oh before yeah ballet cast
it
yeah we got to do something you guys got
to do something wait what what do you
want to do
i was thinking me and uh she said it's a
collaboration is the only fan so i'm
thinking like me and cat like rolly cat
or something like that that's so sexual
though now that
like i think of it because the collabs
are sexual though yeah i want to see a
cloud for you in your big day because
it's usually like collabs with two girls
it's like
oh you had a mojo or like um and like
lana rhodes there's like a lot of porn
stars doing collabs with each other
on their only fans i don't know about
like guys doing collabs actually now
that i think i don't know if the guy
fans would be into you clapping with a
man yeah that's another thing like
yeah what are you talking about yeah
that's not
i mean one you would need to build a
following you know
what are you very specific demographic
yeah what the [ __ ] would you do on only
fans i'm showing dude
together
[Music]
i'm in there just like doing the wet
willy with my little cool willy
the celebrity the airplane
bella uh tiger bite tyler doing the damn
thing
taika has a whole modeling agency on
only fans now
of just like ig thoughts yeah what was
that guy i don't know
uh he was on teen wolf he was uh
bella thorne's ex-boyfriend who posted a
nude video
yeah playing guitar guitar he took our
ideas playing guitar yeah
seriously
4.99 a month oh you know aaron carter's
on there
oh in court yeah he lost oh he did like
a live concert naked
like a stream he streamed a live concert
look at his prizes 2017. he made his
porn debut
yeah things are going well for him
what was that drag queen oh yeah yeah
from what root balls 4.99 a month i
could be killing it
49 20 months 20 dollars a month oh
blackjack
she originally was a stripper yes
originally she started off his district
another housewives uh dorinda you know
all these girls yes she's from new york
they all
what she got our only fans for these
women just probably just like sales
fitness cooking yes decorating yeah oh
i'm not paying for that
tanya who's that that's tana mojo yeah
she is a youtuber she's one of those
girls who makes like millions a month
yeah she shows news huh she's jake paul
girl he'll be killing it amber rose
yeah amber rose is on there that's the
actor right there right who the [ __ ] is
that
he was a singer man only fans bums me
yeah 20 a month i'll pay for that chris
brown
he's just drawing stuff on there though
20 bucks
michael b jordan well he talked about it
right yeah
yeah but some celebrities aren't doing
like fun stuff on there
oh we talked about this earlier fat joe
and dj khaled yep they have one for
twenty dollars
interesting damn all right yeah what
current events you got jen
cat how about that when i get off stage
at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just read a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son